so the fun thing with the serpent is how
does a serpent talk
what and not only that but why is the
serpent's punishment to crawl on its
belly when that's what it does
if you don't know how to read biblical
poetry
if you don't know the formal qualities
of parallelism and expansion
you are missing out on one third of the
hebrew bible
whatever theological background you have
you're going to have your own hypothesis
that is to say your own plot and
narrative what the literary reading
allows you to do is to find new details
that work within that overall plot or
narrative
now the question becomes what's the way
in which the specific details and the
particularities kind of show us the
subtlety and the nuance to really bring
to the forward these theological
insights that are so important to our
traditions
the book of genesis which is the first
book in the bible is profound
serious
and mysterious did all this start
somewhere and if so where
and if there actually was a creator he
would actually have to be outside nature
he wouldn't be just that dense lump at
the beginning of things you'd have to be
something outside that thing to be the
source of it what i hope you'll get from
studying genesis in this course is a
deeper appreciation of the biblical
insights with regards to the human
person psychology our predilection
towards rivalry but also reconciliation
i'm justin jackson professor of english
at hillsdale college
this is the course on genesis
let's begin
[Music]